i
read in the moral animal by robert
wright about how monogamy is a sexual
redistribution strategy
oh yeah yeah so this this really
fascinated me the fact that if you have
one man with many women you allow one
particular man to capture most of the
market whereas if you have one man with
one woman you actually end up um
allowing man number two to get woman
number two whereas previously he would
have been looking at woman number 11
because
women 1 to 10 would have been with man
number one and
that um that kind of explains i think
some of the resentment that you see in
the black pill culture and in the
in-cell culture around these chads these
high-value men that are able to sleep
with many women because they see them as
tying up
available women's reproduction potential
during fertile years when they could
have been dating other people and also
uh how would you say kind of bunching up
the line
moving the queue tighter and tighter
together uh
in a way which has trickle-down effect
that has potentially competed them out
of the dating market
absolutely so these these uh black ball
guys will as the meme goes they hate
chad and stacy and it's it's funny you
mentioned that because i you are correct
so and um the researcher i forget the
name that you mentioned robert wright is
the book robert right yes entirely
correct i think in that
monogamy in in the um the grand scheme
of things is probably a a newer concept
a newer thing that's come about it was
never the case in antiquity that we
engaged in monogamy it was typically
polygamous right we had harems and such
and
i do think that there is an argument to
be made about returning to that
specifically when we talk about
imbalances in the sexual marketplace
with a small percentage of men hogging a
large percentage of women so if we look
at tinder data for example
it's
you know
most of the men on tinder of the
profiles they come across females
they'll swipe right on from 60 of them
when it comes to females they'll only
swipe right on 4.5 percent of them so
that is a massive imbalance just on
twitter usage and that that is even
compounded by the fact that 78 of
individuals that use tinder are male and
so 22 percent of people that use tinder
are female which means of the
demographic of the smallest demographic
in terms of gender the vast majority of
these women are being selected
by the vast majority of men and the
opposite is not true for females
dude i've just realized the implication
of what you're saying and i've never
thought of this before i think about
this [ __ ] a lot right i've read
everything that you've read i've read a
lot of stuff around red pill and black
pill
and i've only just realized that one of
the potential solutions to this is to go
back to a polygamous uh culture
because if women can't get rid of their
hypergamous nature
if we can't rise
raise men's
level of competition up in order to be
able to match the women
one of the solutions to make fewer
people overall be single
is to have many women with one man at
the top and then just leave the men at
the bottom to be cast away that's
[ __ ] terrifying that's terrifying and
it's it's not what we want to do
that is a recipe for disaster that is a
recipe for social upheaval and just
societal disintegration if men are
simply cast aside because they're
inadequate
[ __ ] but that's the case at the moment
that's the case at the moment with it
being non-polygamous
non-polygamous correct so imagine a
society like china where there is a
massive gender imbalance based off of
the the one child policy that they
initiated you know centuries back and
now looking at the the modern sexual
dynamics
what do you think is going to come of
that society in 50 to 100 years if if
all this if our hypotheses here are
correct and this plays its course do you
think are you talking about if you have
one man with many women
yes so the so in essence so as we just
pointed out it's it's that uh polygamous
that's uh polygamy set up where it's one
men with with many women and the rest of
these men who are incapable of attaining
a sexual partner are being left in the
dust but the only thing that they have
to bind together over is their mutual
hatred of chad and stacy of chad and
stacy
yes [ __ ] man that so i never thought of
the fact
that a potential solution and i'm gonna
guess there'll be a utilitarian
rationalist out there who would say that
this is actually an optimal outcome as
long as you can control this underclass
of sexless men
that you actually end up reducing the
number of people overall that are single
by doing this
um but you very very much create
a
a bifurcated society you have the haves
and the have-nots and the matthew
principle comes out with this as well so
i mean as an example i think
robert wright explains i can't remember
it was in 1994 he wrote this book man
it's so pressing it's amazing and um but
at the time maybe the richest man was
like warren buffett or something it's
like a really unsexy example and he
talks about the fact that uh you could
have the richest man in the world that's
worth however many billion and he could
fund the lives
using money as a proxy for resources
which is one of the fundamental things
that women want from a man uh
he would be able to fund
like
10 000 women's lives the same as as one
millionaire
and
when you think about that you go well
okay obviously women want more than just
monetary access they actually want
emotional control
emotional connection they want to be
able to feel like they're part of a
working capacity family and so on and so
forth uh
but when you think about it like that
and if the choice is between being
completely single as a woman as you get
into your 30s
or being one of many with a man who you
know can look after you because he's one
of these
super owners with all of the resources
and all of the status uh
i don't know i don't know how tempting
that ends up sounding
incredibly tempting i would i would
assume because it's it's the prospect of
being funded
pretty much winning the lottery ticket
when it comes to these these warren
buffet types and having to raise
children with a man that you're not
necessarily attracted with or attracted
to or even happy with that doesn't
necessarily provide the sort of life
that you want well the third option is
obviously second is to continue
uh leading a
solo range of life and yes i think that
the from a utilitarian perspective it
would like why why isn't everyone in a
relationship with elon musk like i
should be in a relationship with elon
musk based on utilitarian approach well
it's because he's building he's busy
building rockets i think that's what the
issue is he's not he's not he doesn't
have the time for that sort of thing but
a terrible joke aside yes
your point is well taken yes um
because it's you know what it is i think
it's just it's a matter of
unfamiliarity so this sort of dynamic
that we're describing is not something
that people subscribe to normally right
something which is entirely foreign to
us given the fact that a new the nuclear
family and monogamy is
given the fact that these two things are
still ingrained within within the way we
do relationships today so while it may
not be palatable today it might be
palatable in 10 20 years time 50
potentially that was the
aftershock of the renaissance right the
as roller tomassie founder of the red
pill calls it the one itis
the belief that there is one true love
and this was very much pushed through
the renaissance and then if you think
about popular recent culture you've got
disney movies like aladdin that really
really just fundamentally create this
there is someone out there that is
perfectly built for you and you will
spend the rest of your life together
yes so i i have a bone to pick with
disney i have an axe to grind with them
because i think the disney vacation of
romantic relationships is incredibly
dangerous
so uh so
are you uh your parents still together
yes
yes so
our grandparents on our parents are
they typically have lower rates of
divorce because the
basis the relationship was not
necessarily based on their happiness per
se it was more so
getting things done and ensuring that
these children were raised in a correct
manner right and that often meant
putting up with the opposite sex putting
up with your partner despite the fact
that they're behaving like a [ __ ] on
that specific day today things i think
are different because again it's that
disney vacation of romantic
relationships where if it's not perfect
if it's not a fairy tale i don't want it
and so it is subject to divorce and it
again goes back to that concept of
suffering and hardship and rejection
how good was the relationship to begin
with if once you hit a rough patch you
immediately give up
i think that you see this as well
with the increasing masculinization or
the masculine frame that women are being
encouraged to take to
you know uh don't settle for less clap
back be a boss [ __ ] i know that these
are all kind of funny twitter memes but
they permeate you know
phenomenologically they're in the back
of someone's mind they're in the back of
a girl's mind the fact that he doesn't
deserve you babe all of that sort of
stuff
is
averse to
working through challenges with a man
who is on a par with your sexual
marketplace value um yes and the same
thing goes for the guys it's like plenty
more fish in the sea get over your last
girlfriend by getting under the next one
you know the there are many memes on
both sides of the fence here now they're
being played in different ways the men
are being reminded to reinforce their
masculine traits and the women are being
reminded that a protectionist strategy
is to adopt masculine traits
but again what we're seeing i i need to
i might i need to ring rob for like
three hours and talk it through but
there is a masculine frame a masculine
preference which is being
it's like when you varnish a table and
it's just it's just like a smattering
across everything or it's like the
direction that the wind is pushing
whether that be with how you're supposed
to spend your relationships how you're
supposed to um think about education how
you're supposed to think about your
career
all of these things they really do seem
to be pushing in that direction but
with the women's side of things um yeah
they're being encouraged to not accept a
not a subpar mate but a uh difficult
situation
yeah difficult situation with a
uh equitable mate
yes yes
it's a problem and
obviously you're making the point here
about ideas and memes and it's it's not
just a meme it's it's a mode of thinking
that is being inculcated by young women
and also young men to an extent and it's
incredibly problematic that this this
notion that one must not necessarily
settle it's fine right i don't think you
should ever settle per se but it's it's
more so that you should be very
realistic about what it is that's
attainable and what it is that's out
there and life is unfair and you're not
always going to get what you want and
you're just going to have to deal with
it
and if more people sorry well i was
going to say that if more people were to
come to that realization that they would
just have to get on with things and just
accept them as as to how they are well
it'd be a lot simpler wouldn't it what
do you mean by that
well if if one if if you know the
average female out there who is after
you know gig alpha chad realizes that
she can't actually attain giga alpha
chad and she may in fact have to go with
um you know stormy norman as an example
or joey bag of doughnuts
she'd have uh she'd have a romantic
partner
but it's that notion of settling being
the boss [ __ ] which comes into conflict
with it
that what she's told and what she may
necessarily need are two different
things what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
you